[Musique]
motivation gare à deux heures du grand
spectacle
c'est leur passage obligé par la loge
maquillage pour david et ses collègues
on peaufine les contours et on enfile le
premier costume un rituel et une vie
particulière pour ces artistes qui
passent la plupart de leur temps tourne
et c'est particulier parce qu'on est
loin de chez soi on est loin de sa
famille on est loin de ses enfants pour
ce qu'un or on est loin de tout c'est
une autre vie donc il ya deux
personnages et le david en production et
le david à la maison ces deux des
personnages très différents donc la ga
notre rythme de vie je me bats je pense
plus souvent à moi en coulisses ça
commence à s'accélérer
certains s'isole au calme pour faire des
vocalises
tandis que d'autres préfèrent fouler les
planches de la scène afin de répéter
sous la lumière des projecteurs du
terrain
[Musique]
c'est aussi le moment pour les
techniciens de régler les décors
toujours en musique
même elle n'y touche la première
opérette française un vaudeville
musicale de 1886 qui raconte l'histoire
d'une demoiselle qui quitte son couvent
pour un mariage forcé et qui se découvre
une passion pour la scène
l'occasion aussi de faire passer un
message on est là pour faire rire les
gens
on est là pour les amuser on est là pour
leur dire aussi des choses plus
importantes c'est à dire que peut-être
que en ce moment il ya beaucoup de
misère il ya beaucoup de tristesse mais
qu'il faut garder la joie la joie d'être
au monde
le mot d'ordre est la bonne humeur alors
à une demi-heure de rentrer sur scène
quelques artistes pousse la chansonnette
et accueille le public en spectacle si
la troupe du palazzetto bru zane et sa
centaine de membres tourne déjà depuis
un an un peu partout en france
les tourangeaux auront encore jusqu'à
demain soir pour venir les regarder
avant que mam elle n'y touche parts l'an
prochain pour paris et les planches
américaine de broadway